here is someone who was born a boy they  don't feel comfortable being a boy they  don't feel like they're right in their  body and in their mind they feel more  comfortable with playing with the girls  they he they like playing with the dolls  and the makeup and whatever it may be  that well I know that's  exposing them that's exposing them to  like mental issues at such a young age  yeah so you think being trans is a  mental issue  of course it is it's not a phys it's not  a biological uh you don't have to say of  course take it down a notch no no but  it's true it's not it's not a biological  one it's a mental one right if you think  you're something that you're actually  not that's in your head